We can go through a
similar analysis to the one that we already went through, but where we also keep track
of this additional system.
It's a little bit messier because we have the additional system, but
the idea is exactly the same, here's a very quick summary.
This is the initial state, here's the state after
the controlled NOT gate,
and here's the state after
the Hadamard operation.
If we expand these things
out, we can express that state as you can see right here,
that's the state immediately
before Alice's measurements, and if we go through the
possibilities just like before
and we consider what
happens when Bob applies whatever operation he's supposed to apply,
then we find that indeed
the correct state comes out and the protocol works as expected.
In this table by the way, we're using the letter R to
refer to this additional system, and you can see that we're
using a pretty simple trick,
which is to decide that we would rather, at least momentarily, order
the systems as B, R, A, Q
because that's more convenient for writing the states right here.
According to the diagram, the systems should be
ordered as B, A, Q, R,
but as long as we make it clear, we can choose a different
ordering that's more convenient.
In a nutshell, everything that's happening in this analysis is the
same as what happened in the simpler analysis,
but we happen to have
these additional vectors, gamma zero and gamma one
that basically come along for the ride.
We always have gamma zero
when there's a factor of alpha and gamma one when
there's a factor of beta and at the end of the day,
it all works out correctly.
This is actually not at all surprising, we have a physical process that acts like the identity
operation on a qubit
in an arbitrary quantum state, and there's only one
way that that can happen and that is that the operation
is the identity operation.
That's a little bit easier to explain using the general formulation
of quantum information, but the point is that by linearity,
we really didn't need to go through this additional analysis.
Once we know that
teleportation works correctly for a single qubit in isolation, we can conclude that there's
only one possible thing
that can describe what the protocol does, and that is that it implements
the identity operation where a qubit comes in right here
and it comes out right here, effectively acting as a perfect
noiseless quantum channel.
Just a few quick remarks
about teleportation before moving on to the
second example of the lesson, which is superdense coding.
First, I think it's important to clarify that teleportation is not an application of quantum information, it's a protocol
and specifically it's a
protocol for performing quantum communication.
In order for teleportation
as I've described it to be useful, there has to be some reason for performing quantum communication.
Second, it's reasonable to speculate that teleportation could, one
day, become a standard way
to communicate quantum information, and specifically a process known as entanglement distillation
might potentially be used
as a way to communicate Qubits reliably. If Alice and Bob know they're
going to be communicating quantum information or they
have the need to communicate
quantum information, then this process of entanglement distillation
could be used to convert a larger number of noisy e-bits
into a smaller number
of high quality e-bits that could then be used for noiseless or near noiseless teleportation.
The idea is that the process
of entanglement distillation isn't as delicate in some sense, we could accept losses and
if it doesn't work out,
then we could just try it again, whereas the actual Qubits that
we would like to communicate might be considered much more precious.
Of course, this is all speculation, but the point is that it isn't difficult to hypothesize situations
in which teleportation
could be a very practical
way to communicate Qubits.
And the final point
concerning teleportation is that the idea behind teleportation and the way that it works
is quite fundamental
in quantum information and computation, teleportation is really a cornerstone of quantum information
theory and variations
on the idea also often come
up, it's just one example, there are proposals for
implementing different quantum gates
using teleportation, but
where different initial states and measurements are
chosen so that the outcome
is to apply a chosen operation
rather than to communicate.
The next example is superdense coding.
Like quantum teleportation,
superdense coding is a protocol and what it accomplishes is complimentary to teleportation.
Whereas teleportation allows
one qubit to be transmitted using an e-bit and two
classical bits of communication,
superdense coding allows
two classical bits to be transmitted using
an e-bit and one qubit of quantum communication.
So, in short, superdense coding allows for the transmission
of classical information and the reason it's
called superdense coding